now inside Ukraine both sides continue
to exchange Heavy Artillery fire as they
prepare for new offenses many civilians
are caught in the crossfire
raymondocencio visited a village in the
South that is often hit by Russian
Rockets
seventy-year-old Natalia Koga never
imagined War would hit her backyard
a gift from Russia she says
debris from a grad rocket
like these fired from russian-controlled
Ukrainian territory
a roof in tatters a door blown from its
hinges a wall demolished kogut lives
just next door when this house was hit
what did you feel what happened big
big lotions the Earth was shaking and so
was my house
at about 7 A.M when this home was hit
luckily there was no one inside but not
every family not every household was
lucky in this Village
Victor Carlin and his wife Luba both 44
lost their lives
now orphaned their teenage daughter
sneijana and her seven-year-old brother
in intensive care this fall removed
farming Village has no apparent
strategic value since the war started
half of this Village's 600 people have
fled their children Spirited Away mostly
elderly left behind
Victor and Luba are the first deaths in
this community caught between two armies
how do you want them to be remembered
the whole village respected them so much
for me they were the best
life is fragile and death random here on
the edge of War
for CBS mornings raymie inocencio Solon
Chucky Ukraine